nous interrompons ce programme le
département dans la défense vient de
confirmer qu'un objet non identifié
venait de pénétrer dans l'atmosphère
d'objets d'origine extraterrestre a
atterri sur terre
il faut qu'on sache dans quel but ils
m'ont demandé de diriger la mission
s'est jamais que six mois tu sais tout
ce déroule comme prévu ouais je
reviendrai je te le promets
c'est la mission la plus importante de
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est l'heure
on se dirige vers une planète peuplée
d'extra terrestres
j'ai trouvé quelque chose il y en a
beaucoup de ces trucs dans la galaxie
vous le premier contact avec une
civilisation extraterrestre est risqué
tu veux qu'ils aient des morts c'est ça
on est tous ici pour une seule et même
raison
protéger la vie des gens qu'on aime et
qui sont encore sur terre qu'est ce que
c'est
je vais rentrer sur terre
accroche toi
tu vas arriver si va se produire sur
terre
je dois sauver l'équipage
et la terre
imaginez si on déclenche une guerre
interstellaire en franchissant cette
frontière
on n'a pas trop le choix